well now as the Conservatives descend
into almost civil war and the Labour
leader facing criticism for not sharing
a platform with the Prime Minister you'd
forgive David Cameron for perhaps
warning his old coalition colleagues to
be back making the case to remain in the
european union of course they still are
the lib dem numbers though are thin on
the ground after their devastating
general election result last year well
if all my business secretary Simmons
cable joins me now from Twickenham a
very good morning to servants and as you
are survey from outside government all
this conservative in fighting what's
your take on that and its impact on the
referendum campaign well during the
agenda election you remember we have
this slogan it's Cameron or chaos and it
looks as if we're getting Cameron and
chaos but anyway that's that sort of
grief from last year I'm trying to focus
on the referendum campaign I think what
was said this morning about the
immigration target was actually quite
interesting Mr Gove and Boris Johnson I
mean I am the Liberal Democrats argued
throughout the coalition that it was not
sensible to have a rigid immigration
target that couldn't be met I mean it
isn't just because of migration from the
European Union you can't control
emigration from Britain I mean we're not
these Germany or North Korea and of
course if you managed to reduce British
emigration if Richards people stay at
home and work at home of course you then
you then make the the net immigration
position worse so it was a foolish
target to him there so you've got
different groups of people he would
asylum seekers workers families overseas
students or not ot immigrants at all all
in the same number and we urged them to
drop this target because it wasn't
achievable but and they repeated it
again in 2015 so I think they the basic
point that Mr Gove is making is actually
valid in its own terms that they
shouldn't have had this but I don't
remember him speaking up at the time
about it yeah but what you're also
saying by implication not in by
implication what you said to him
presumably to his face when you're in
government is relax about it its due to
economic growth in the main that so many
members of the
European Union want to come to the UK to
work and if the economy should turn down
a bit they'll go away again and it's
okay then for UK citizens to go and work
in other EU countries yeah that's
exactly right and then that is the case
we would make that the emigration
immigration is very much driven by the
economy Britain is currently going
through a phase of growth and we we all
hope it will be sustained we've got very
low unemployment at the moment again we
hope it will be sustained it may not be
but but as long as it is you're going to
get people coming to the UK looking for
work and filling vacancies and I think
the the key development this morning is
this the big story of large numbers of
people who do economics my field in
business world economic society
economists are often accused of having
two different views on everything but
actually on this is you are virtually
unanimous that the economic case for
staying in for remain has largely been
won the economic evidence is pretty
overwhelming businesses arguing this
case again overwhelmingly most
independent assessments of the likely
consequences are all pointing in the
same direction a what's your view on
this suggestion from one of the back
benches within the Conservative Party
that sir mr. Cameron is causing so many
problems within his party annoying so
many members of the party that they may
well come for him after the referendum
even if he's won its and remove him and
suggestions there could be a another
general election this year well that's
their private grief I don't want to get
involved in who should be leading the
Tory party it would actually very
difficult to hold a German election this
year because we now have fixed-term
parliaments and Mr Cameron got elected
and his party won in seats like mine in
Twickenham on the basis that we're going
to provide us with five years of stable
government and not run to the country
again in chaotic conditions I mean he's
won the election he's got his mandate he
should get on and run the country and I
hope his party show a bit more of a
sense of responsibility than I currently
showing what you feel any sympathy for
him having seen it up
mohsen personal yes i did i do have some
sympathy with him yeah I didn't agree
with him on everything but I do have
some sympathy with them he had to come
to a decision on British membership he
came to decision he's followed through
on it is tried to renegotiate our
conditions I think actually delivered
some reasonably sensible outcomes and
he's now trying to lead this campaign
which I'm part of and yeah I do have
some sympathy with him and people who
were perfectly happy to go along with
him in the in the last parliament are
now turning on him and it doesn't
reflect very well on the moment thing
hmm and do you think in terms of the
tone of the remain campaign I mean
you've heard the accusations of project
fear and over egging things and flying
kites that are never going to happen or
do you think he's just making and
obviously you and others are just making
some perfectly reasonable points well
there is you know there are so there are
extremes on both sides of the argument
of course but I think that we are trying
to make a dispassionate case and then
the most extreme and discredited comment
sameer this this analogies with hitler
and napoleon and this 350 million a day
which had been denounced by the
independent statistical authority and
then they're coming from the other side
I am sure there are people on our side
you occasionally exaggerated but I think
on balance we are trying to make a
reasoned case and wherever possible
making use of people who are politically
independent who have no axe to grind I
mean the the key intervention last week
was the Institute of fiscal studies and
highly respected body that detects all
governments for their fiscal performance
and nobody can question their integrity
they came out very clearly in terms of
the cost of the budget of leaving the
European Union bodies like the IMF and
then there's no extra ground whatever in
this and taking a very strong and clear
view the world trade organization which
is precisely the World Trade and people
at bro's chance I say we should rely on
the world trade oh no they're saying
it's all very difficult if we leave and
those that those are the key people that
we should be listening to but but I mean
you know it must be said not everyone
within the remain side is perhaps so
thoughtful as you when they get
information
like that there's a bit of spin added to
it we end up with third world wars and
never-ending recessions do you think
they are overdoing it a bit on the
remain side well that there is
exaggeration I conceded that point a few
moments ago I I don't expect that we're
going to get Armageddon either way that
I think the balance of evidence is very
clearly that it is in Britain's
interests particularly on the economic
side in terms of living standards and
jobs if we stay in and I think it if the
arguments couch to that level and not in
terms of some vast explosion that would
happen if we leave I think people will
get that and they already have I think
the economic arguments been largely one
great talking Jose ever so Vince thank
you very much indeed sir Vincent all
there